what i hope to do in this video is give
you a satisfying proof of the product
rule so let's just go let's just start
with our definition of a derivative so
if i have
the function f of x and if i wanted to
take the derivative of it
by definition
by definition the derivative of f of x
is the limit
as h approaches 0
of f of x plus h
minus f of x
all of that over
all of that over h we want to think of
visually this is the slope of the
tangent line and all of that
but now i want to do something a little
bit more interesting
i want to find
the derivative
with respect to x not just of f of x but
the product of two functions f of x
times g of x and if i can come up with a
simple thing for this that essentially
is the product rule
well if we just apply the definition of
derivative that means i'm going to take
the limit
as h approaches 0. in the denominator
i'm going to have an h
in the denominator i'm going to write a
big
it's going to be a big rational
expression in the denominator i'm going
to have an h
and then i'm going to evaluate this
thing at x plus h so that's going to be
f of x plus h
g of x plus h and from that i'm going to
subtract this thing evaluated f of x or
sorry this thing evaluated x so that's
going to be f of x times g of x
and i'm going to put a big awkward space
here and you're going to see why in a
second so if i just if i evaluate this
at x that's just going to be minus
f of x
g of x
all i did so far is i just applied the
definition of the derivative instead of
applying it to f of x i applied it to f
of x times g of x so you have f of x
plus h g of x plus h minus f of x g of x
all of that over h limit as h approaches
0.
now why did i put this big awkward space
here
because just the way i've written it
right now it doesn't seem easy to
algebraically manipulate i don't know
how to evaluate this limit there doesn't
seem to be anything obvious to do
and what i'm about to show you i guess
you could view it as a little bit of a
trick i can't claim that i would have
figured it out on my own maybe
eventually if i
were spending hours on it and i'm
assuming somebody was fumbling with it
long enough they said oh wait wait look
if i just add and subtract the same term
here i can begin to algebraically
manipulate it and get it to what we all
know is the classic product rule so what
do i add and subtract here
well let me give you a clue
so if we have
plus
actually let me change this
minus
f of x plus h g of x
i can't just subtract if i subtract it
i've got to add it too so i don't change
the value of this expression so plus
f of x plus
h
g of x
now i haven't changed the value i just
added and subtracted the same thing but
now this thing can be manipulated in
interesting algebraic ways to get us to
what we all love about the product rule
at any point you get inspired i
encourage you to pause this video
well to keep going let's just let's just
keep exploring this this expression so
all of this is going to be equal to
it's all going to be equal to the limit
as h
approaches zero
so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to look at
i'm going to look at this part
this part of the expression
and in particular let's see i am going
to factor out an f of x plus h
so if you factor out an f of x plus h
this part right over here is going to be
f of x plus h
f of x plus h
times you're going to be left with g of
x plus h
g
of
it's a slightly shader different shade
of
green
g of x plus h that's that there minus g
of x
minus g of x
whoops i forgot the parentheses
oh it's a different color
i got a new software program and it's
making it hard for me to change colors
my apologies it's not a straightforward
proof and the least i could do is change
colors more smoothly all right g of x
plus h
minus
g of x that's that one right over there
and then all of that over this h
all of that
over h so that's this part here
and then
this part over here
this part over here and actually it's
still over h so let me actually circle
it like this so
this part over here
i can write as
so then we're going to have
plus
actually here let me let me let me
let me
factor out a g of x here
so plus g of x
plus
g of x
times this f of x plus h
times f of x plus h
minus this f of x
minus
that f of x
all of that over h
all of that over h
now we know from our limit properties
the limit of all of this business
well that's just going to be the same
thing as the limit of this as x as h
approaches 0 plus the limit of this as h
approaches 0.
and then the limit of the product is
going to be the same thing as a product
of the limits so if i use both of those
limit properties i can rewrite this
whole thing
as
the limit
let me give myself some real estate the
limit as h approaches 0 of f of x plus h
of f of
x plus h
times
times the limit
as h approaches 0 of all of this
business
g of x plus h
minus g of x
minus
g of x
all of that over h i think you might see
where this is going very exciting
all right
plus
plus
the limit let me write that a little bit
more clearly plus
the limit as h approaches zero of g of x
our nice brown color g of x
times now remember product here the
limit
the limit
as h approaches 0 of f of x plus h
of
f of x plus h
minus f of x
minus f of x
all of that
all of that over h and let me put the
parentheses where they're appropriate so
that
that
that
that
and all i did here the limit the limit
of this sum that's going to be the sum
of the limits that's going to be the
limit of this plus the limit of that
and then the limit of the products is
going to be the same thing as a product
of the limits so i just use those limit
properties here but now let's evaluate
them what's the limit and i'll do them
different colors what's this thing right
over here the limit as h approaches zero
of f of x plus h well that's just going
to be
f of x
now this is the exciting part what is
this
the limit as h approaches zero of g of x
plus h minus g of x over h
well that's just our direct that's the
definition of our derivative that's the
derivative of g
so this is going to be
this is going to be the derivative of g
of x which is going to be g prime of x
g
prime of x so you're multiplying these
two
and then you're going to have plus
what's the limit as h approaches 0 of g
of x well there's not even any h in here
so this is just going to be g of x
so plus
g of x
times
the limit
so let's see this one is in brown
and the last one i'll do in yellow times
the limit as h approaches zero and we're
getting very close to the drum roll
should be starting limit as h approaches
zero of f of x plus h minus f of x over
h well that's the definition of the
derivative of f of x this is f prime of
x times f prime of x
so there you have it the derivative of f
of x times g of x is this and if i
wanted to write in a little bit more
condensed form it is equal to
it is equal to
f of x times the derivative of g with
respect to x
times the derivative of g with respect
to x plus
g of x
plus g of x times the derivative of f
with respect to x
f with respect to x or another way to
think about it
this is it's the first function times
the derivative of the second plus the
second function times the derivative of
the first this is the proof or a proof
there's actually others
of the product rule